i definitely believe cooking is in my
blood i feel like cooking chose me food
is
life
food is everything hi my name is ayo
cherry and i am a private chef i started
cooking when i was eight and luckily i
got to work at my aunt's restaurant and
then my grandmother is a phenomenal cook
she taught me literally everything i
know my private chef journey started a
little crazy i began working with a
personal trainer who was preparing meals
for his clients
and he asked me would i like to prepare
the meals for his clients and from there
i got a lot of other personal trainers
and i was preparing food for everyone
and a chef friend of mine asked me if i
would like to cook for little wayne one
day i went and i tried out and he liked
the food luckily
i made a well-done steak and some potato
chips
and all of a sudden i was a private chef
to a
celebrity having your own business feels
a lot like what i hear people with
children say about parenting
it's rough there are days i hate it i
don't know what i'm doing but you love
it and you get up and you just keep
doing it and then eventually like good
things happen
my workspace is people's homes cooking
in someone else's kitchen is a lot of
trial and error because no one has as
many things as i do if a lot of
adjusting to the situation the first
time we go from where i bring everything
i have because you just never know my
kitchen is organized by my things my
clients things i have more phones than
any one individual should need i have a
lot of spatulas i just have multiples of
a lot of things and i basically set up
everything i need for meal prep in one
area and i section off my things about
spices sweet and savory i have two
refrigerators and quite frankly i need a
third
and maybe a deep freezer a typical week
for me starts on friday friday is admin
day we do all the invoices from the week
before we create menus we write prebliss
and we really get ready to move into the
week saturday is a free day for me i try
to keep
one solid day for myself sundays i go
grocery shopping i buy everything to get
me through monday and ideally in a
perfect world tuesday on mondays i wake
up around 4 a.m i prepare vegan meal
prep for two separate clients and that's
10 meals each i drop one of them off i
drop the second one off and then i go to
the grocery store to get anything extra
that i need for my clients that i cook
for after my drop-offs on monday
tuesday i do the same thing i cook for a
family of four
i wake up i go to grocery store i cook
for them wednesdays i wake up i eat i
drive an hour from my house i stop at
the grocery stores and any markets or
whatever along the way and then i cook
for a family of three
dinner and then i meal prep for them for
the following day on thursdays i go back
to my same clients from monday and i
complete the rest of their weeks worth
of meals then i go home and i pass
out
because that is the end of the week
it is a lot personal time is difficult
to work out my friends are always
fussing at me like what are you doing
i'm like i'm making a menu if i have a
long car ride somewhere i'm going to
find some time to write something send a
text work in some sort of way the door
of clients rotates a lot in the
beginning because you're trying to
figure them out they're trying to figure
you out sometimes your culinary style
just simply doesn't match for someone
and it's a lot like being in
relationships sometimes they're just not
your people catering for events is my
time to shine we put on like this
display for their families it's always
so pretty and it's always
so extra i put like gold leaves on the
turkey like there's usually a lot going
on but
i always have this thing with my clients
where i'm like are we showing out or are
we just keeping it cool because that
lets me know like what level
of event we're having this most recent
thanksgiving for my clients i made
southern food they had
family in from the uk and they don't
really have southern food there
obviously so i made a huge southern
feast there was a baked mac and cheese
because duh there was air fried chicken
i know some of my southerners are
rolling here you'll be fine if l.a if
air fried chicken i did some air fried
turkey wings and legs and breasts and
you know just broke down the whole
turkey um i did collard greens and green
beans and you know just mash
sweet potatoes mashed potatoes with all
the classics and we also added a rack of
lamb to thanksgiving which isn't
typically a southern classic but it's
good and thanksgiving is all about
what's good i feel like i care
on an almost maternal level about my
clients i like to add touches that i
know will excite my clients something
else i like to do for clients is make
sure it looks really appetizing because
you eat with your eyes first and meal
prep can get really stale so i really go
out of my way to make a fully composed
dish and make sure it's pretty in their
colors and use some like really good
knife cuts and give them you know some
stuff sliced on the bias or some really
pretty peppers instead of just green
peppers you know just going the extra
mile so it looks visually appealing you
are feeding people's families it's not a
small task and i do take a lot of pride
in the amount of knowledge i have to
make sure this food is like nourishing
it's correctly prepared it tastes good
you know food is something that brings
us all together and you are literally
responsible for creating that moment for
your clients every single day when i
label the meal for meal prep i leave
them instructions on what i think would
be the best way to reheat it it does
really help to know like hey we have an
air fryer if we put half of this meal in
the air fryer we can put some of it in
the oven and it'll get as close to the
texture and freshness as it was when it
was prepared
it is difficult
when you are a private chef to say no it
is difficult to say no to opportunities
it is difficult to say no especially
when you're in film with home and in
their face
it is hard to go from ha ha he he hear
some rope here's your food
no you can't call another 10 people it
is a difficult thing to set those
boundaries it is difficult to
make sure i have time for me time i'm
slightly getting better at it but it is
a very difficult thing to say hey i'm
not going to work i'm going to do
nothing
that is a hard thing to do without
feeling super guilty about it so being a
private chef always has a multitude of
opportunities you know you're not just
in people's homes doing meal prep you
could be
traveling with a client i've flown on my
client's private jet with them to
australia you could also be working you
know overseas for people there's a lot
of different opportunities in the
private shelf world
i physically don't think i could do this
forever the hours are long you know
you're carrying a lot of stuff so after
this i think i could do a cookbook or i
could have a food truck i have a lot of
ideas in my head but i'm pretty much
open to whatever the universe has for me
my advice to any young chefs who are
interested in the private sector is
talk to other private chefs when i moved
to los angeles i leaned on so many chefs
here and the amount of help you get from
other people in your sector is
invaluable even before private shipping
i think starting in a restaurant teaches
you so many of those basic skills you
need that will help you through anything
no matter what you end up doing so if
you love food i say go for it i mean
you're creating happy moments for people
there's nothing better than that
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you